Just as from many others.
My childhood and adolescence,
we're in a way defines by jk rowling,
magical world of how we boller growing
up about a year or two younger than
Harry Potter was in the books when they
were released a reds and still reread
the magical adventure mysteries that
went from children's books to as the
neuro titus dates increasingly dark,
increasingly nuanced treatments of
character and blood.
This gradual shift,
of course,
whilst carefully planned out by jk
rowling long before she started writing,
she spent several years carefully
constructing the full saga and writing
extensive background stories for the
major characters before she started on
the first book.
Now,
rollings books are filled with
references to mythology and other
writers.
As John granger states,
Ronin storytelling reveals traditional
artists three with symbols and themes
borrowed from Dante Shakespeare,
the inklings,
and other literary greats I Republican
things teams like friendship,
good versus evil and racism and
oppression.
However,
I want to focus on what I considered the
two most important themes in how we
bother.
It's philosophy of laugh
debt.
From the very beginning.
We can see death.
Death's plays a major role in Harry
father and it becomes clear that in jk
Rowling swirls,
death isn't seen in binary terms in the
wizarding world to can be nuances
between being death and being alive.
The primary example of this is of course
for the Moritz who chases immortality by
two murder,
ripping a solo in pieces and storing
them in valuable artifacts.
He cannot die as long as the pieces of
his saw our bounce to earth within these
artifacts,
I think for the moth is clearly inspired
by Gothic fill such as Frankenstein
Dracula and Jacqueline and hate all our
intelligence scholars who attempt to
meddle with the loss of nature with life
and death.
The law for it already is strikingly
clear from the data's there,
Carrie.
There are doctors counts and involve
them.
Warts case a lord as John granger stays,
they are men of my thin body.
Without spirit,
there is no end even there.
It is out of a bow
like many godick villains for the artist
is only concerned with the eternal life
of his mind and body.
Instead of turn the life of his spirit
and saw these willing to split and maim
has saw into pieces in order to preserve
his earthly might embody.
Even though he's worn that spending your
soul is a terrible natural thing to do
and that's a soul is to remain in tech.
Yes,
healing a nation against nature.
Proning stake on the soul as separate
from the body of course goes against the
way by logical and natural scientists,
he consciousness,
they see physical and chemical processes
in the brain as the cost of emotional
and rational consciousness which
disappears if one dies.
The body is all there is the ID off.
A separate soul is just a kosher
projection.
We create.
However,
although Ronan's notion of splitting a
soul in multiple parts is quite
original.
The idea of a separate soul that needs
to remain in tact or in other words and
tainted is spite of many religions
around the world,
and this brings me to my central
arguments.
That's to Harry pulled the saga is very
much influenced by religious and
specifically Christian symbolism and
narratives.
There are many examples,
specific symbolism in Harry Potter.
That's can be linked to Christianity
starting with the name,
how he father.
Some have suggested that it's over first
to Sephora or biblical verses where
[inaudible] is another word for God's
search as is a a 64 eight but now,
oh Louis,
the Arthur follow.
We are the clay and Dow or other.
Well,
heavy according to John Granger is a
wordplay on air.
How we polar is this the era of garth.
Okay,
one question.
Push this even further and draw
comparisons between Donadoni and Garth,
which would mean that Harry and
Dumbledore's army represent Jesus and
his disciples
professor,
he had nothing to do with that.
It was me,
most noble of you,
Harry,
but as has been pointed out,
apostrophe cleared.
It says
double doors.
Further,
draco is the Latin word for boats,
dragon and a serpent,
which are biblical symbols for Satan.
Revelation 22 states.
He sees the dragon,
that ancient serpent who is the devil
and Satan and bound him for a thousand
years.
Well,
malfoy comes from the French malfoy,
which translates to Beth or evil faith.
DRACO malfoy is this a serpent of evil?
Faith.
Seven Sophia,
of course,
the serpent is seen lots in Harry Potter
and it is one of the strongest
representations of the devil starting
with the serpent.
Of course,
that's seducers Adam and eve in the
garden of Eden.
Rolling symbolism based on animals
clearly comes from medieval Christian
bcra which were animal stories where the
animals are infused with biblical
meaning in Christian Bcra,
the snake and bus least equal
representations of Satan.
Dare foods are the phoenix and stack
while the lion,
which is of course the symbol different
door represents Jesus.
In revelation five five for example,
Jesus is referred to as the lion of the
tribe of Judah and finally though is a
symbol of maternal off
after all this time
or
John Granger also makes the argument
that and Harry Potter and the Chamber of
Secrets,
the sort of Griffendor is a symbol for
the Christian Cross.
Thus Harry as a representation of Jesus
fights off the devil bus,
at least with a sword that is symbolic
of the Christian Cross.
I could go on,
but I would refer you to John Granger's
book looking for God and Harry Potter
for more symbolism on the brother and
narrative level.
The Harry Potter.
Sarah can of course also be seen as a
Christian narrative.
It is an essence,
a story about laugh,
more specifically sacrificial laugh
conquering
Beth.
The forces that defeat evil and Harry
Boulder are almost always forces of
good.
They are healing tears,
sort that appears through bakery and
loyalty,
a strong force of happiness and of
course laugh itself.
La Fin Christianity put Texas saw and
pro fence a terrible faith in the
afterlife and like Jesus died for our
sins.
Harry sacrifices himself to protect his
loved ones
after which he has resurrected in front
of his disciples.
Now I myself as an atheist,
well most days and an agnostic on Psalm,
was quite surprised to find search,
strong Christian influences in books.
Death defined my childhood,
yet I wouldn't effort dismissed the many
lessons that can be found in how he
father John granger describes how
reporter as novels that satisfy a
spiritual hunger in a secular society,
seasoned them.
The power of traditional Christian
literary arts.
And although I agree for the
nonreligious I see in Harry Potter or a
story that is perfect to introduce to
children or for grownups to reflect upon
the normality and inevitability of
death.
In Harry Potter,
a fear of death is seen as a filter
relation with death.
Although trout,
he put her many people in some way come
back from the afterlife.
This is always described as a temporary
or negative experience.
People resurrected by the resurrection
stone are unhappy and don't belong on
earth anymore and of course there's for
them worth who was fear of death lease
into evil,
x of murder and damaging a saw.
This slowly turns him less and less
human,
which is emotive debt and trey to yield
cof traces back to Oscar Wilde's picture
of Dorian Gray.
It's voting's fishing of death and Harry
Puller is death.
Death can infect be transcendence.
One can truly become the master of death
by living with laugh and creating death
as an old friend when he comes.
We see this when Harry is in limbo after
for the more it's quote unquote kills
him where Dumbledore tells him he can
move on if he wants to.
All right,
thank you.
So desire,
you'll be able to board a train
ready to take me
on.
But I think there's also an important
nonreligious lesson on death,
which can be seen in how he bother the
lesson of accepting the debt or friends
and loved ones.
The lesson of realizing that the death
live on in our hearts and in our
memories as Albus dumbledore tells us in
the third book and Cvs Stenosis in the
third movie,
it's cruel that I got to spend so much
time with James and Lillian new,
the little note this,
what's the lovefest never,
rarely leaves
and you can always find
it here
and I think it is this lesson that lace
at the core of the story of how he
father in book seven Luna answers the
question from the ego of Raven claw by
suggesting that a circle has no
beginning all the loft ones.
Harris last live farm as an inseparable
part of him and although ODF dice in a
way,
their circles continue because by giving
their names to his kids,
Lily James Serious and the others
Devonne as much in Harris children as
they live on in himself.
All right.
Thank you all so much for watching.
This was a very hard one to make.
I deleted the whole video the first time
because I just felt that it wasn't good
enough.
And I'm still not completely satisfied,
but yeah,
it's a,
it's finally here.
Tomorrow I'm gonna delve deeper into
Harry Potter and it's Christian
symbolism in the patron.
Only video a fire.
Everyone else,
please subscribe and leave your comments
below.
Domeless is a already finishing up his
video.
So the wait for the next video,
it won't be as long.
Uh,
and uh,
we'll see you all next time.